проросійські сепаратисти на сході
україни видуть пропагандистську ну
проти уряду в каїрі та заході та рублі c
замовлення fcom із Москви такого виставку
dish ви німецькі журналісти спливу вас
цієї дикої total і каналу zdf
на уяві аналізу б tukku даних про
прилюдно них в інтернеті польщу серію
розслідування чого ти ж не показала в
передачі frontal 20d
найбільшим вона висловила ще не їх
треба силі крісло не вимолювати від сили
системи змієм і тебе система абсолютно
контролем вона тут на мага юті він і коти
конт активно за неї висновки може бути
тачки 2 ми з точки зору системи тут
на магніті контролювати і дуже даний
контент і для тегу розлучення бути апарат
цензури
діяльності ЗМІ повністю контролюється
розум і спецслужбам це вся кава ми
самі міліція виплив близько 11 гігабайте в
даних з так дзвонова міністерство
інформації з апарату стив стався на
вас не
і dc про 10000 м або в голови та тіла
відомства олена нікітіна і справа всяких
правил і німецькі журналісти до них
рук по стежки в інформаційний текст
стратегія з апаратистом вигляд церкви
2015 руку стратами в деталях розписувати
екшеном з дітьми в одесі пропаганда
приклад щодо українського уряду slide
розвивати і образ хунти росія з путіним
на ту помсту майк піддаватися вимкнена
позитивному світлі чи стратегія пропонують
у рязанова роду інста нізації про світ
бабуся в йошкар тортури для путіна а бу
дет і малює портрети путина ми-то
перуку на ту аудиторію що нас її не
соромно та україни в г пшона путіну
сепаратисти вже систем але вид
зціджувати на вигляд у мене в закордонних
змі творити руслі дачі і на уявити
угу складу та
аж ніяк не списку журналістів праска а то урію
прикладом по стежках аеропорт ери
міжнародних інформагентство рейтер то
осушує прес та уткнувся ми сварилися та
краще в межах факту та fury in the
волосся на факти для нас було до його
вижним усім із правді смоли та ви стримо
як функції так і пропаганда за будь-якого
куті або за допомогою документа століття
виходять із семи систем
пустим запискам розслідування засвітило
сліди прикутих рідних та видути добрий
сказати до кремля фірм я наприклад
центр політичної кон'юнктури у Москві
абу напряму
до адміністрації російського президента
і до документації проходить ти до брови
обрамляю а.п.
сам путін неодноразово замикає шумів
що ж москва даєтеся розпорядженню
сепаратистів на донбасі